emily in one of your videos i think
you've said that raising money for the
movie is the easy part no no that's not
what i said
i don't want people to see the film
that's the hard part people think
raising money is the hardest part it's
not getting anyone to see your phone
when it's finished is way harder okay
well we've spoken to filmmakers who
spent three years five years ten years
or more raising money for their films
how can distribution be harder than that
uh
jet well okay so there's that's that's a
loaded question right because if you're
going through traditional financing
methods
those are incredibly dependent upon
cast and director and the lead investor
and then somebody gets burned and they
pull out and all that stuff um
at the three to five million dollar
level which is still something that
crowdfunding doesn't
regularly achieve
um it's hard for a separate set of
reasons
then um
like that part of financing is hard for
sort of a separate set of reasons the
reason distribution is harder is um
that the you know the powers that be
that will reach down and sort of offer
you distribution only do it to .04
of the films that are made every year
right so you have to do it yourself and
for the most part we have not been given
good information we don't have great
data out there to help us build smart
business models we're still learning
about all the tools that are available
to us there's a tremendous amount of
misinformation there's a lot of bad
actors out there that will tell you that
if you pay them ten thousand dollars
they can help you get the distribution
deal that will really help you um
there's there are myriad difficulties
built inside of distribution but
ultimately
getting enough people to watch your
movie
um
is is tremendously difficult and it
takes a lot of time and resources
particularly if you think you should be
making five million dollar films that's
a lot of people buying movie tickets to
pay that money back
right um and because audience is built
one person at a time
so i understand that uh sedan spark is
coming up on two years yeah congrats yes
i know you're having okay and i know
you're having a big party for that and
fairly soon
have
any of the projects on spark made more
money
on the distribution side than they have
on the crowdfunding side um we don't
know yet uh it take this so the
interesting thing one of the reasons why
we're in such a tumultuous period is it
takes a long time to take a movie from
beginning all the way
to the end so the films that crowdfund
the very first films that crowdfunded
with us many of them are only just
entering the festival circuit kind of
now because you know we have these sort
of festival seasons
um
and uh very few of them have have come
onto the streaming platform yet
and the other thing is like i don't
think they're going to make all their
money back on our streaming platform
which is why we're building distribution
in 2015 we'll be distributing out as
well
because i think our job as the platform
is to give filmmakers a chance to with a
crowdfu successful crowdfunding campaign
guarantee themselves some meaningful
distribution beyond a single platform um
what we know is that when films are on
multiple particularly digital platforms
um when they're on multiple digital
platforms they do better on all
platforms
right so being on a single platform is
not a good plan and we don't we don't
constrain them that way at all it's
totally non-exclusive
i'm hoping that in 2015 we will finally
get to see the sort of full circuit
model play out but
many of our films were waiting to go to
festivals and in the meantime we are
trying to build into our process the
meaningful distribution deals that by
the time they do come to us they'll go
on our platform they'll go out to
various other
platforms
and opportunities and really be able to
make money i will say this
our original idea was extraordinarily
idealistic
they'll just crowdfund and then they'll
stream and they'll make all their money
back it's just it was never going to be
that simple right and this is why we've
explored these other opportunities for
distribution um because you have to meet
their your audience where they want to
be we can't i think it's silly to kind
of try to force them force their hand in
a new direction right now as audiences
are feeling this terrible
um kind of onslaught of platforms and
devices and all of these things and the
good thing about having weighted is now
you have a you know a chromecast or an
amazon fire stick and anything that's on
your laptop is on your tv you know sort
of it's sort of amazing but just in a
couple of years whereas we maybe should
have built for you know roku and apple
and all these things they just built a
sticky plug into your computer you can
stream anything that you're streaming
right onto your television you know so
the nice thing is the technology is
making it easier for all of us to be on
all devices
and we should try to be on all devices
because some of your audience is going
to consume it on their mobile phone get
over it some of your audience is going
to want to consume it on their tv and
that's great and a lot of your audience
is going to be streaming it curled up in
their bed on their laptops which maybe
means you don't have to shoot on 6k raw
all the time i'm just saying but anyway
you